er spricht mit einer das beste spiel
aller zeiten ohne weiteres davon
herzlich willkommen wir heute meine
damen und herren es mittlerweile schon
zweiten episode vorne
wie ist bereits beim ersten video vom
wenn man jetzt mit luca der fall weist
auch dieses heutige video wieder
freundlich unterstützt wurden von der
google play playon kampagne und ich
finde darf können die auch mal kläglich
kurz klatschen ihre ich habe mir heute
am montag selbstverständlich wieder
meine mobile mondays gaming brille
angezogen und zudem auch ein mega cooles
spiel ausgesucht dass wir auf dem google
pixel zocken werden und zwar dass hier
das ding sieht aus wie ein scheißhaufen
ist aber ein alien und dieses alien
trägt den namen pumpen müssen wir uns
kümmern wir müssen uns um ihn pflegen
wir müssen ihn füttern und so weiter und
so fort also es ist wirklich wie so eine
art halbgott
dafür haben wir oben auch verschiedene
anzeigen und das ist eine ziemlich nicht
so gute anzeige eine ahnung warum die
dritte anzeige da oben nicht komplett im
grünen bereich ist allerdings bringt
hier unten die seife das heißt ich gehe
jetzt mal auf die seife verziehen sich
neben die seife und leistung entsperrt
wasche ihnen das erste mal dass ich tief
man habe ich jetzt in meinem leben noch
nicht bekommen user die seite von pur ab
dann schaue nach den spielen im
spielezimmer okay also nie jetzt die
dusche und
da halo er sauber aber dass da oben ist
immer noch im gelben bereich und
irgendwie kacke seine augen auch
ziemlich krass aber gut okay ich würde
sagen wir wechseln mal den raum und
gehen rüber ins labor
was ist denn das das ist nicht
wie wahr was kann er reden
willst du das nicht wie geht es dir denn
so wird es mir auch gehen wenn ich mich
sehen würde also den gesundheits trank
will anscheinend ich haben aber macht
auch keinen sinn weil um die gesundheits
anzeige grün ist das hier ist das
spielezimmer da wurde uns nahegelegt
dass wir hier mal hingehen einem nämlich
von den ball
ich glaube der ist ziemlich geil auf den
ball aber gut okay mir den ball und
meist einfach mal hier hin
liegt jetzt
da rechts
weil es
das soll
mit dem
machen 2000 jahre später ja
weimar zurück klicken mal auf spiele und
wir heilige mutter gottes sind dass
viele spieler ich würde sagen wir fangen
mal oben an mit sky jump wie hoch kann
kommen versuche auf viele plattformen zu
kommen oder zu fallen ok spielen am es
ist ein bisschen so wie doodle jump
dementsprechend springen hoch
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen beim wenn man es mit
luca eure serien mit den beschlüssen
gamer der welt als wenn ich jetzt direkt
verklagt habe das ist doch kann auch
nicht sein hier mich verarschen alter
bin ich einfach zu blöd oder ist dieses
spiel wirklich nicht so einfach wie es
aussieht also gut okay ich bin jetzt mal
hier an der seite so ein bisschen hier
vorne rum hier vorne drauf hier nun auf
denen hier auf denen ihr die münze
mitnehmen hier die mitnehmen hier vorne
hier lagen hier leise ich bitte meine
herren jetzt seien zwar ein alter ich
war ja richtig krass ok erreichte 2 50
meter insgesamt das hab ich auf jeden
fall krank hingekriegt 100 meter jahr
gegeben 50 auch blablabla
ich würde sagen wir gehen wieder zurück
und spielen was ist der unterschied
zwischen sky jump und sky hobbys aber
auch egal wir haben auf jeden fall nun
das erste spiel gespielt namen sky jump
das heißt jetzt spielezimmer haben wir
erfolgreich haben wir uns erfolgreich
von daher klicke ich jetzt oben mal
wieder auf den rechten pfeil und wir
sind im schlafzimmer
ich kann die lampe ausmachen und geht
jetzt das da oben rechts nach oben oder
bin ich blind ich würde sagen wir machen
die lampe mal wieder an
auf jeden fall ist der dritte symbol nun
voll grün also das war anscheinend dass
spieler symbol von pur also wenn ihm
langweilig ist ist das dann anscheinend
dann im schlafzimmer hier können uns auf
jeden fall nochmal den schrank dann
gucken wir haben hier körperfarbe wir
haben nur braun können uns aber auch
noch andere farben kaufen dieser
gegenstand ist gesperrt du kannst
entweder warten bis das freischalten
kann es oder jetzt schallte es für 1919
verschicken den später dass sie
tatsächlich gar nicht mal so gut aus ich
würde sagen wir ändern provida in
braunem dass er auf jeden fall besser
aus dann haben wir noch outfits da
kommen uns auch sachen kaufen können
alien lka kaufen eine polizei uniform
anziehen die wir erst ab level 70
erreichen
okay da muss ich wohl ein bisschen mehr
noch zocken allerdings würde ich sagen
verlassen wir dann an der stelle wo das
schlafzimmer im und gehen mal in die
halle
da unten das mikro hallo
nein er spricht mit einer das beste
spiel aller zeiten
luca - shop.de kaufen
die fresse du lappen ich würde sagen ich
mach das mikro jetzt mal aus und wir
können unten links auf draußen klicken
dann befinden wir uns hier im garten
keine ahnung was wir hier machen können
nicht mal auf die wolke ach so ich kann
die ich kann die wolke a
ich kann die wolke hier gießt die blumen
haben hier unten ist auf jeden fall noch
ein handy
da können wir unser leistung angucken
unsere freunde haben mir freunde loading
gebe deine e mail adresse ein
die bringt ja auch nix da habe ich auch
keine freunde haben auch ein gästebuch
und sein account echt also im garten
können wir glaube ich nicht so viel
machen wir mal weiter dass der
spielplatz ich kann ich kann fußball
spielen also es ist anscheinend nicht so
dass man sich wirklich die ganzen sachen
ihnen die kaufen muss das geld oder so
sondern man kann es auch alles mit
spielen in dieser app tatsächlich
bekommen
also gibt ja auch tatsächlich einige
apps wo man schon sehr krass in die
in-app-käufe schiene rein gerät
allerdings ist es hier anscheinend
wirklich so dass man die ganze zeit sich
irgendwie geld holen kann also diese
ingame-währung diese münzen um sich
damit halt irgendwie seinen pool
irgendwie cooler aussehen zu lassen eine
neue hautfarbe zu kaufen neue
polizeiuniform ab level 70 bin ich auf
jeden fall mega cool ich denke jetzt
allerdings man oben rechts auf den pfeil
drauf und das ist das ist unsere karre
dort ist da der sonst skateboard gehen
wir allerdings mal wieder ein stückchen
weiter
das ist unser haus da kriege ich jetzt
einfach mal auf eintreten und dann sind
wieder drin das ist die küche m und
hunger ist das essen das essener essen
alles klar also ich hab gerade erst mal
was gegessen haben hier unsere steht bei
ist dreckig gehe ins badezimmer und
putzer es mit wasser und seife okay also
putz tatsächlich schon wieder dreckig
aber ich habe eigentlich gerade erst
gewischt bzw
gewiss ich habe den gerade erst
gewaschen das heißt jetzt schon mit der
dusche drüber und
das war es doch der dazed doch nicht mal
dreckig hätte ich würde sagen wir gehen
zurück in die küche und geben prognosen
ab bommels genau hier kommen können noch
mal ein paar mehr pommes könnten noch
ein paar kirschen genau perfekt ja oder
mal ein paar kirschen hypo mir nochmal
tierischen hier nochmal auch bei
kirschen und da und die auge haben sich
verändert
lena hat er war die ganze zeit
anscheinend wirklich ziemlich ungerecht
und hat deswegen so große arbeit gemacht
und hat sechs liegt auch so gibt es in
takt ist natürlich stark dass mir die
ganze kaka erst jetzt am ende des videos
hier aufgefallen ist im badezimmer bin
auf jeden fall gewaschen im labor
gesundheitsziele da genau auch nicht
haben hier oben rechts ist auf jeden
fall nicht so gut mit dabei ich habe das
mal drauf geklickt energie ist er 63
prozent das heißt ich glaube muss
wirklich schlafen
und während er schläft lädt er dann
seine energie auf oder bin ich falsch
darüber informiert welche ecken slater
wir können und seine energie trank
kaufen
trinkst du den x und jetzt haben wir
alles geil ich dachte wirklich als das
spiel zum ersten mal gesehen habe und
das soll überhaupt kein display speck
seien an den spieleentwickler oder keine
ahnung an wen aber ich dachte wirklich
dass werden stücke dieses ding aber es
ist anscheinend tamagotchi man kann sich
richtig was den kümmern man kann dem
essen geben trinken geben ezb man kann
mit dem spiel spielen dass sich halt
auch krass wenn jemand spielezimmer
schauen bei den spielen was es hier
alles für eine auswahl gibt foodwatch da
müssen wir drei oder mehr in einer reihe
auswählen hier haben wir drei wenn ich
denen hier nach oben ziehe haben wir
hier drei da haben wir drei da sind auch
wieder direkt drei nebeneinander hier
haben wir trauern
ja
da wirklich ein cooles spiel hätte nicht
gedacht dass das ganze game so komplex
ist also dass da so unfassbar viele
andere mini games noch in diesem game
schon drin sind von daher würde ich
sagen
an der stelle ich mal die lampe haus und
willst du nicht schlafen
er guckt mich an wie ich damals meine
eltern meinten die zweite halbzeit
fußball braucht jetzt nicht mehr gucken
du gehst jetzt ins bett menschenrechte
sind ziemlich abstoßend allerdings
büchern erster dennoch das heutige video
jetzt beenden meine lieben freunde wenn
euch die zweite teil von mobile mann der
ist mit luca gefallen da will ich mich
sehr darüber einen daumen hoch von euch
unter dem video hier freuen danke auch
an google play dass sie im rahmen der
playon kampagne auch dieses heutige
video hier gesponsert haben 100
ehrenpunkte an euch wir befinden uns
ihnen allerdings auch in der endart des
heutigen videos und zwar einerseits das
video vom letzten montag verlegt wo ich
dann bist du da im rahmen der mann der
es mit luca serie gespielt habe und hier
ist auch ebenfalls das spielfeld was ich
heute gespielt habe und zwar das könnt
ihr euch gerne runterladen dem ich auf
das logo drauf klickt schreibt mir gerne
in die kommentare was ihr für einen
score bskyb erreichen könnt und wie ich
würde sagen wir sehen uns nächsten
montag wieder wenn es wieder heißt